BUT.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
WE WILL GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED WILL START OF THE SUBS
THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE WE HAVE
QUITE A FEW.
ISSUES COMING UP BEFORE US I
WANNA GO HAVE AND.
I SEE SOME OF OUR COLLEAGUES
HERE JUST SO I WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT WE HONOR THEIR TIME FOCAL
HAD TO GET STARTED.
.
AND WELCOME TO THE MARCH SIXTH
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE. TODAY WE
HAVE SIX BILLS ON THE AGENDA.
AS A REMINDER WE ALLOWED TO
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT AND TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION FOR EACH
BILL. EACH OF THESE WITNESSES
SHOULD LIMIT THEIR TEST ONE TO
TWO MINUTES ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES MAY ADD ON THEIR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION BY STATING
ONLY THEIR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION.
AND.
THAT SEEDS ONCE WE HAVE OUR
MEMBERS ARE PRESENT WILL GO
AHEAD AND.
STARTED THE COMMITTEE IN THE
MEANTIME WE'LL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
*.
LAWYERS.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
OKAY SO I SEE MISS. NC
THAT IS A.
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO GET STARTED
WITH MISTER JONES SAWYER
.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF IT'S A
PLEASURE TO APPEAR BEFORE MY
FAVORITE COMMITTEE.
AND UNDER THE BRILLIANT
LEADERSHIP OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO.
THAT THE GOOD ONE.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS A A. B.
EIGHTEEN NINETY TWO WHAT ALLY
STATE LAW ESTABLISHING
TRANSITIONAL. CASH ACCOUNT FOR
IT BENEFITS WITH FEDERAL LAW TO
ALLOW THE STATE TO EXTEND
BENEFITS TO FAMILIES LEAVING
STATE. AND LOCALLY FUNDED CATCH
ASSISTANT PROGRAM.
UPON CERTIFICATION BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
FEDERAL LAW AND REGULATIONS
ALLOW STATES TO ADMINISTER
TRANSITIONAL SNAP
A BENEFITS KNOWN AS TRADITIONAL
CAO FRESH IN CALIFORNIA.
FAMILIES LEAVING CASH ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS FOR UP TO FIVE MONTHS
WHEN INDIVIDUAL SUCCESSFULLY
TRANSITION. OF FROM CASH
ASSISTANCE TO A NEW JOB THEY
OFTEN HAVE. NEW WORK RELATED
EXPENSES THAT MAY NOT HAVE THE
MONEY NECESSARY TO MEET THEIR
BASIC NEEDS AS THEY WAIT FOR
THEIR FIRST FEW PAYCHECKS.
COUNTY SUCCESSFULLY ADMINISTERED
A TRANSITIONAL CAL FRESH PROGRAM
AND WE BELIEVE THAT A. B.
EIGHTEEN NINETY TWO WILL HELP
THEM EXTEND BENEFITS TOOTHERS
THAT ARE FEDERALLY ELIGIBLE.
ADDITIONALLY AB EIGHTEEN A
NINETY TWO WOULD EXCHANGE THE
DEFINITION OF PARTICIPANTS
FACING MULTIPLE BARRIERS TO
ENTRY. AND EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT COUNTIES MAY
SERVE TO A PARTNERSHIP WITH AN
APPOINTMENTS SOCIAL ENTERPRISE
DOES CHANGE WOULD ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE WITH MULTIPLE BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT INCLUDING PEOPLE ARE
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS. HAVE A
PRIOR CONVICTION. OR ARE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS WILL BE ABLE
TO ACCEPT CATH ABOUT CAL FRESH
EMPLOYMENT AND TRAINING.
FINALLY.
BECAUSE ACCESS TO ONLINE
RESOURCES AN APPLICATION FOR THE
OFTEN A BARRIER TO WORK A. B.
EIGHTEEN NINETY TWO WOULD ALLOW
CALTRAIN H.. E. N. T. DOLLARS TO
BE USED TO COVER THE COSTS
INTERNET OR TELEPHONE.
SO SERVICES THIS BILL WAS
BROUGHT TO ME BY HUNGER ACTION
LOS ANGELES HERE TODAY TO
TESTIFY AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
IF JENNIFER BARTOLO FROM THE.
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE JUST GOV ART LOW
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY OUT WITH GRATITUDE
TO THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS WHO
HELPED US OUR COUNSELING WHICH
WITH THE AUTHOR STAFF.
.
WE.
ARE PRACTICAL SPONSORED THE
SPELL MOST BECAUSE IT WILL
EXPAND OPPORTUNITIES FOR SELF
FOR SELF SUFFICIENCY FOR PEOPLE
CURRENTLY ON CAL FRESH. WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR EMPLOYMENT AND
TRAINING?
INVESTMENTS
UNDER CURRENT LAW OF WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO EXPAND THESE
OPPORTUNITIES UTTERMOST CAO
FRESH RECIPIENTS OF CIVIL.
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF CATFISH
DEPENDS HER ELIGIBLE FOR A STATE
Y. CONTRACT Y. WHEREBY FEDERAL
PAST THREE DOLLARS A FIFTY FIFTY
MATCH CAN BE. PASSED THROUGH TO
ORGANIZATIONS.
AND COUNTY.
AND GOVERNMENT ENTITIES SERVING
THAT'S POPULATION.
AGAIN REALLY PROUD TO COSPONSOR
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION AND AB
ARCHER ABOUT THANK YOU.
THE GOOD AFTERNOON TERMINATE
THEM CLOSE BONDS OF THE EARNED.
THE BILL AND WE SUPPORT THE BILL
BECAUSE WILL BASICALLY MAKE MORE
FOOTSTEPS AVAILABLE.
TWO FAMILIES WHO GET OFF OF
WELFARE. THEN TO TAKE THE TIME
TO TRANSITION AND THIS WOULD
JUST HELP TO MAKE A THOUGHT SOFT
LANDING AND THE SELF
SUFFICIENCY.
AND ONCE WE WERE TO DRIVE OUT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
COUNTY WELFARE.
OUR COMMITTEE JUST WANTED TO SAY
THAT AND EXPRESS OUR THANKS FOR
MAKING THE BILL WORK FELT
THANKS.
JANET CANNELLA MATILDA'S DEFENSE
FUND A CALIFORNIA AND I'D LIKE
TO LINE MY COMMENTS WITH MY
COLLEAGUE.
FLUORESCENCE ARE AMONG POVERTY
AND WERE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE
SPELL THINK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY MEMBERS.
ANYBODY IN THE AUDIENCE IN
OPPOSITION.
NO THANK YOU AND I I WE HAVE A
QUORUM CAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
RUBIO.
HER HERE.
DOCTOR CHOI.
ARAMBULA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
LAUGHS.
STONE.
THURMOND.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A QUORUM.
OKAY THANK YOU I'VE A MOTION BY
A MISTER STONE A SECOND BY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RADIUS.
GET ANY QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS.
MR MAIENSCHEIN.
OUT HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL
MISTER CANCER I THINK IT'S MADE
BILL ALTHOUGH I THINK IN YOUR
OPENING REMARKS WHEN YOU'RE
PRAISING HIS RUBIO YOU FORGOT
THE MINORITY MEMBER OF THE.
COMMITTEE TO PRAISE HIM TO BUT
SHORT OF THAT I THOUGHT YOU DID
AN EXCELLENT JOB ON THE
PRESENTATION HAPPY.
BY ABOUT.
THANK YOU ANY THERE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS.
GAVE MISTER JONES SAWYER WHICH
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU AND I I
WOULD THINK DEVICE CHAIRED A
COMMITTEE TO BRINGING THAT TO MY
ATTENTION BECAUSE OF HIS
BRILLIANT LEADERSHIP.
AND LEADERSHIP THAT WE WILL BE
ABLE TO GET THIS BILL OUT OF
THIS GREAT COMMITTEE SO THANK
YOU MR MAIENSCHEIN. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOUNG WITH THAT I HAVE A
MOTION TO.
IT'S DO PASSED TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS.
CAN CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
REPEAL.
RUBIO AYE DOCTOR CHOI.
ARAMBULA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I ADDRESS.
THERE'S AYE STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
BILLS GET FOUR ZERO TO.
OKAY BILL PASSES WITH THE FOUR
ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU.
OKAY IS MISTER NAZARIAN AREA.
OKAY MS RAYOS.
YOU
.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
ALL MEMBERS.
EXCELLENT. AB TWO THOUSAND ONE
STANDARDIZES THE DUTIES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES OF FAMILY
CHILDCARE HOME EDUCATION NETWORK
OR F. C. C. H. E. N..
CONTRACTORS AND PROVIDERS.
THIS LEGISLATION WILL ENABLE THE
STATE TO PROVIDE CONSISTENCY
ADDRESS REIMBURSEMENT RATES
SUPPORT CAREER DEVELOPMENT
PATHWAYS FOR PROVIDERS.
AND USE THE APPROPRIATE
ASSESSMENT TOOLS TO EVALUATE
FAMILY CHILDCARE HOMES WITHIN
THESE NETWORKS.
FAMILY CHILDCARE HOMES PROVIDE A
WARM AND NURTURING CHILD CARE
SETTING AS WELL AS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR LEARNING. THAT
CAN BE FOUND NEAR THE CHILD'S
HOME OR SCHOOL.
THIS TYPE OF CARE SERVES ALL
AGES OF CHILDREN IN A HOME
SETTING AND IS FREQUENTLY AN
OPTION FOR PARENTS SEEKING CHILD
CARE FOR SIBLINGS.
THIS MEETS THE NEEDS OF FAMILIES
WORKING NONTRADITIONAL. HOURS
SUCH AS WEEKENDS EVENINGS AND
ROTATING SHIFTS.
FAMILY CHILDCARE HOME EDUCATION
NETWORKS OFFER A PROMISING
PRACTICE MODEL FOR THE STATE TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF FAMILY
CHILDCARE OPTIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
HOWEVER EXISTING LAW LACKS.
CONSISTENT ADMINISTRATION
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE NETWORKS
SO TOOLS USED TO MAKE QUALITY
ASSESSMENTS MAYBE MAY NOT BE
APPROPRIATE TO FAMILY CHILD CARE
HOMES SETTINGS.
IN ADDITION EXISTING LAW DOES
NOT PROVIDE FOR UNIFORMITY IN
PROVIDER RE EVER REIMBURSEMENT
RATES OR ONGOING EDUCATION FOR
PROVIDERS.
SMALL FAMILY PROVIDERS AND THE
VULNERABLE CHILDREN THEY SERVE
SUFFER AS REIMBURSEMENT RATES.
FALL BELOW WORKABLE LEVELS
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE PROPERLY
PROVIDE FOR WORKING FAMILIES.
BECAUSE LOSING A CARE GIVER
THREATENS THE ABILITY OF PARENTS
TO WORK.
AND INTERRUPTS A CHILD'S
COGNITIVE AND SOCIAL
DEVELOPMENT.
HERE TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF THE
BILL. ARE DONNA SNEERING JR.
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
FOR THE CHILD CARE RESOURCE
CENTER. AND ADAM NORTH
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT MANAGER
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHILD
DEVELOPMENT ADMINISTRATORS
ASSOCIATION.
THINK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DONNA SNARE ENTER AND I'M WITH
THE CHILD CARE RESOURCE CENTER
WE ARE A. NONPROFIT CHILDCARE
SERVICES ORGANIZATION THAT
SERVES SAN BERNADINE ON LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. AND WE'VE BEEN
AN ADMINISTRATOR OF A FAMILY
CHILDCARE HOME EDUCATION NETWORK
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SIX.
I AM AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MENTIONED FAMILY CHILDCARE HOME
EDUCATION NETWORKS HAVE BEEN
PART OF CALIFORNIA'S CHILD CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM SINCE THE
NINETEEN NINETIES.
SOME THROUGH DIRECT CONTRACTS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
AND SOME THROUGH CONVERSIONS OF
EXISTING GENERAL CHILDCARE
CONTRACTS WHICH WERE ORIGINALLY
SET UP TO ADMINISTER CENTERS.
BUT BECAUSE OF THE FAMILY NEEDS
WERE CONVERTED TO WORK THROUGH
FAMILY CHILDCARE.
THESE PROGRAMS OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE HIGH
QUALITY TITLE FIVE STANDARDS AND
A HOME BASED SETTING THAT GIVES
FAMILIES MORE FLEXIBLE HOURS.
AND SMALLER MIXED AGE GROUP
OPTIONS FOR THEIR FAMILIES.
AS I SAID WE'VE HAD ONE OF THESE
PROGRAMS SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
SIX AND TO OUR YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE WE'VE COME TO
RECOGNIZE THE VALUE OF THE
PROGRAM IN A VARIETY OF WAYS.
FIRST IT OFFERS A SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE SPACE TO A FAMILY
ENOUGH FAMILY CHILDCARE SETTING
THAT SUPPORTED WITH TRAINING AND
RESOURCES TO MEET HIGHER QUALITY
STANDARDS.
AND IT ALSO PROVIDES A NETWORK
OF SUPPORT TO PARTICIPATING
PROVIDERS ONE OF THE THINGS I
LIKE TO TELL FOLKS IS WE'VE HAD
THIS PROGRAM SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY SIX WITH ABOUT FORTY
PROVIDERS. AND OVER THIRTY OF
THEM HAVE BEEN WITH US SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY SIX AND IN A
FIELD BUT STRUGGLES WITH
RETENTION THAT SAYS SOMETHING
FOR THIS MODEL BECAUSE THEY HAVE
THE NETWORK OF EACH OTHER AND
THE SUPPORT OF THE AGENCY.
WE'VE WORKED WITH OUR COLLEAGUES
AROUND THE STATE TO IDENTIFY THE
BEST PRACTICES SO THAT WE CAN
CREATE A MORE STANDARDIZED
SYSTEM AND WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO
BE HERE CO SPONSORING THE BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR HEARING
OUR.
BILL TODAY WE'RE VERY HAPPY
HERE TO BE IN SUPPORT AFFECTIONS
WE KNOW WHAT A WONDERFUL AND
IMPORTANT PROGRAM THIS IS TO THE
FAMILY CHILDREN. OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO ECHO MY
COLLEAGUE SENTIMENTS ON THIS
BILL. ARE ALSO AT THE PRESENT
DEVELOP MANAGER LED TO SPEAK TO
THE ASPECT THAT WOULD ENCOURAGE
THESE PROVIDERS TO GET THE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
I'D NEED IT TO INCREASE THE
QUALITY OF THESE PROGRAMS WE
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT THE
FLEXIBILITY OF THESE PROGRAMS
ARE TO OUR FAMILIES. I KNOW FOR
MYSELF YOU KNOW I WOULD HAVE
THROUGH MY CHILD OFF AT FIVE
THIRTY THIS MORNING TO PICK HIM
UP EIGHT THIRTY AT NIGHT THAT'S
NOT SOMETHING THAT ALL NOT. YOUR
TYPICAL CENTERS CAN DO BUT
FACTIONS CAN PROVIDE AGAIN IN
THAT WARM FAMILY HOME
ENVIRONMENT.
I THINK TO ENABLE THESE
PROVIDERS EVEN FURTHER WITH
THOSE PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
AND THE QUALITY STANDARDS AND
THE ASSESSMENT TOOLS NECESSARY.
TO BE OF SUPPORT EVEN FURTHER TO
THOSE CHILDREN TO BE A WONDERFUL
THING SO.
OUR ORGANIZATION AGAIN IT'S CO
SPONSOR IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND THANK YOU FOR
HEARING US TODAY.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY OTHER OF.
MEMBERS OF THE AUDIENCE IN
SUPPORT.
THE UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS APPS
ME IN ASCII YOU WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE SPONSORS ON THE
TOPIC IN THIS BILL FOR QUITE A
LONG TIME. AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH HIM CONTINUING
TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS IN THE BILL
WE REPRESENT ON FAMILY DAYCARE
PROVIDERS WHO ARE INFECTIONS
RIGHT IN A HISTORICALLY THERE
BEEN SOME ISSUES AND THE
SPONSORS HAVE BEEN REALLY KIND
AND BE WILLING TO WILLING TO
LISTEN TO US TO HEAR WHAT. OUR
CONCERNS ARE AND TO INCLUDE THEM
IN THE BILL SO WE APPRECIATE
THAT.
CATHERINE GONNA I HAVE PROXY
FROM AIRING EVIL IF FIRST HAVE
CALIFORNIA FIRST HAVE
CALIFORNIA'S IN SUPPORT.
PATTY PER NEUBERGER FROM THE
CHILD CARE LAW CENTER IN SUPPORT
HIM WE ALIGN OURSELVES WITH THE
COMMENTS ALREADY MADE.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY ONE IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU HAVE A MOTION THE
SECOND.
KING OF ANY QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS.
OKAY WHICH LIKE CLOTH.
YES AB TWO THOUSAND ONE IS JUST
THE FIRST STEP PROVIDING THIS
CONSISTENCY FOR THESE PROGRAMS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND AND.
THIS BILL WOULD PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CAN YOU CALL VOTE
PLEASE.
REVEALED AYE REVEAL AYE DUCKED
CHOI NO DOCTOR CHOI NO ARAMBULA.
BUT OUR LOW AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE PANTS AYE
VARIOUS AYE STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE BALLISTIC.
SWING. THEM AND KILL AS AT SIX
ONE MOVES ONTO APPROPRIATIONS
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MR HAS VERY
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES.
AB NINETEEN OH NINE WOULD SIMPLY
EXTEND THE SAME LANGUAGE
TRANSLATION RULES THAT APPLY TO
RECIPIENTS OF IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES TED. I JUST US
PROVIDERS UNDER CURRENT LAW THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
TRANSLATES ALL WRITTEN MATERIALS
INTO THE FOUR. MOST COMMON
LANGUAGES SPOKEN BY A JUSTICE
RECIPIENTS STATEWIDE.
WHICH ARE ENGLISH SPANISH
CHINESE AND ARMENIAN. COVER NO
SUCH LAWS EXIST FOR HSS
PROVIDERS AS A RESULT ROUGHLY
FORTY PERCENT OF AYE JUSTICE
PROVIDERS ACROSS THE STATE WHO
SPEAK LANGUAGES OTHER THAN
ENGLISH RECEIVE PROGRAM
INSTRUCTIONS TIME SHEETS TAX
NOTICES FORMS. AND OTHER
IMPORTANT MATERIALS IN A
LANGUAGE THEY DO NOT PRIMARILY
READ OR SPEAK.
THESE FORMS ARE OFTEN
COMPLICATED AND PRESENT AN EVEN
GREATER BARRIER FOR PROVIDERS
WHOSE PRIMARY LANGUAGE IS NOT
ENGLISH. TO MITIGATE THIS
DISPARITY SOME COUNTIES HAVE
DEVELOPED THEIR OWN TRANSLATIONS
OF KEY PROVIDER MATERIALS
DESPITE HAVING NO FUNDING TO DO
SO. THIS BILL IS A SIMPLE.
WAY AND THAT AND NECESSARY WAY
TO BRING LANGUAGE PARITY BETWEEN
HSS RECIPIENTS AND PROVIDERS TO
REDUCE DUPLICATED WORKLOAD AND
PROVIDE CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE
STATE. WITH ME I HAVE.
KATHY SANDERLING FROM THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
AND MILDRED RODRIGUEZ SHOVEL THE
A. AND A TRUSTS US A PROVIDER
FROM SUTTER COUNTY AND HER
TRANSLATOR TO EXPLAIN THE
BARRIERS SHE FACES. AS A SPANISH
SPEAKING IHS HAS PROVIDER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST
KATHY CENTER LIKE THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
WERE REALLY PLEASE BE A CO
SPONSOR OF THE LEGISLATION. AS
YOU HEARD FOR MISTER NAZARIAN AB
NINETEEN OH NINE EXTENDS THE
SAME LANGUAGE TRANSLATION RULES
THAT CURRENTLY APPLIED AYE TO
ASSESS RECIPIENTS TO THE
PROVIDERS WHO DON'T NOT READERS
SPEAK ENGLISH AS WHILE. THE.
CRILLON RAGS REQUIRE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TRANSLATE ALL WRITTEN
MATERIALS INTO THE FOUR MOST
COMMON THRESHOLD LANGUAGES IT'S
BASED ON A PERCENTAGE THRESHOLD
ON ACCORDING TO THE DSS RAGS.
AND THAT INCLUDES.
ENGLISH SPANISH CHINESE AND
ARMENIAN THAT.
AS YOU HEARD NO SUCH
REQUIREMENT EXISTS FOR PROVIDERS
EVEN THOUGH WE ESTIMATE FORTY
PERCENT OF OUR PROVIDERS YOU NOT
SPEAK UP OR READ ENGLISH. ON AS
THEIR PRIMARY LANGUAGE THIS
ISSUE IS JUST REALLY GROW MORE
VISIBLE I THINK IS THE PROGRAM
HAS GROWN AND AS IT'S BECOME
MORE DIVERSE AND AS NEW
REQUIREMENTS HAVE BEEN PUT INTO
PLACE. THAT REALLY DIRECTLY
AFFECT PROVIDERS A REALLY GOOD
EXAMPLE IS THE ELECTRONIC TIME
SHEETS THAT HAVE JUST BEEN PUT
INTO PLACE. ON THIS IS A GREAT
SYSTEM THAT IS ALLOWING OUR
PROVIDERS TO REALLY GO IN MUCH
MORE CLEANLY AND QUICKLY AND
INPUT THEIR WORK INFORMATION AND
THEN RECEIVE THEIR CHECKS BACK.
HOWEVER THE.
THEIR PIECES IN THE TIME SHEET
INSTRUCTIONS THAT APPLY SOLELY
TO PROVIDERS AND THOSE ARE NOT
TRANSLATED INTO ANY OTHER
LANGUAGES OTHER THAN ENGLISH.
THERE ARE PARTS OF THE RECIPIENT
HAS TO COMPLETE THOSE ARE
ACTUALLY TRANSLATED INTO THE
THRESHOLD LANGUAGES AND SO ON
WHAT WERE SEEING IS ERRORS BEING
MADE CONFUSION BEING BECAUSE
THAT JUST DOESN'T NEED TO
HAPPEN.
THIS IS JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF MANY
OF THE TYPES OF MATERIALS THAT
WOULD BE ABLE TO GET TRANSLATED
STATEWIDE ON AN ONGOING BASIS
WITH THIS LEGISLATION. AS YOU
HEARD WE HAVE ON MY TO SAYS
PROVIDED HIS GRACIOUSLY AGREED
TO TELL HER STORY AND SOME OF
THE STRUGGLES THAT.
I THINK I SHOULD JUST YIELD THE
REST OF THE TIME TO HER AND
THANK YOU AND.
DRIVE VOTE TODAY.
HON.
THE MAIN ENORMOUS MEAN THAT
EVERYBODY'S.
YES SIR BUT I'LL PUT AWAY THE
ORDER. IN THEIR LIVES.
HE.
GET A COUPLE UNIT FOR A GREAT
DEAL.
A.
MY NAME IS MOTHER RODRIGUEZ
SEVERAL HERE AND I AM AND I JUST
OF PROVIDING YUBA CITY AND THE
U. D. W. MEMBER.
YEAH.
IT.
GOODNESS WOUND.
WE WILL NOT SONORA THEN OPEN
DONE USE.
IMMIGRANT ONLY THAT.
TENNESSEE DOT I DO A LOT BUT I
NOTICE IT MAY STEVE SAY. IT
DOESN'T BELIEVE THAT THE IDEA
DELIBERATE ME THING.
BETTER MONEY SAID IN SU CASA.
LITTLE DID I GET IT IS THAT.
I CARE FOR AN EIGHTY YEAR OLD
WOMAN IN MY COMMUNITY WHO NEEDS
HELP WITH BATHING DRESSING AT
ALL THE DAILY ACTIVITIES THAT
ALLOW HER TO REMAIN AT HOME.
WHERE SHE WANTS TO BE?
IS DIRECTLY.
BOY.
BUT A COMPETITIVE ALMOST DAYS ME
ESPECIALLY INSEPARABLE HONDA
PROMOPRO IS ORDER.
THEY AYE.
OKAY.
LOG WRITING LACE.
THE LOVE DIFFICULT DEDICATED
THEIR MEAL.
OKAY GET THEN YOU CAN PRINT THAT
THEY'VE YOU KNOW.
I LOS RB SO THAT I.
IN MOST ARTICLES NORTH STATE
GOBBLED SAYING IT'S BY NO ONE.
MEANWHILE BELIEVE YOU'LL.
I'M HERE TODAY TO SHARE WITH YOU
MY EXPERIENCE WORKING AS A NIGHT
TO SAYS PROVIDER WHO DOES NOT
SPEAK ENGLISH AND THE
DIFFICULTIES I HAVE FACED.
DO TOO I JUST THAT'S NOTICES NOT
BEING TRANSLATED INTO SPANISH
AND OTHER LANGUAGES.
HASN'T THAT MEANT THEY PUTS A
SPIN BICU OUT BUT WHAT I'M.
PULLING DOT THE UC.
WHAT CAN NO LONGER IN PLACE NINE
PM GOING THIS?
RECENTLY I WAS SUSPENDED FROM
THE I JUST AS PROGRAM FOR NINETY
DAYS BECAUSE I DON'T SPEAK
ENGLISH NOR UNDERSTAND IT.
GOT MORE TUESDAY THROBBING.
GONE BUT THAT I THOUGHT IT WOULD
BE ABLE THE ICE.
IF THE FECES.
BUT I WILL JUST BROKE WAY THE
ORDERS.
YOU ALSO YOU KNOW THE.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW FILLING OUT.
I JUST US TIME SHEETS IS
DIFFICULT FOR MANY PROVIDERS I
AM ONE OF THEM.
ONE THOSE PROBATE OTIS COMPLETE
BANG.
IN GO IN GOING I THOUGHT MENTAL
SORT IDEALS.
YOU THINK I'M WRONG.
THEY MIGHT SEE US SORT OF.
INCLUSO WHAT I THINK THEY HAVE
BEEN RECEIVING A HOST BY NINETY
DOLLARS.
WHEN PROVIDERS FILL OUT
TIMESHEETS INCORRECTLY AND CLAIM
TOO MANY HOURS EVEN BY ACCIDENT.
WE RECEIVE VIOLATIONS.
LET WHAT AT THAT IF BY NINETY
DOLLARS LOOKS BUT AVAIL IT. FOR
THEMSELVES TO BRING LEGAL THEN
BUT O'DONNELL PORTAL OPENED THE
OBVIOUS.
YOU THAT BOY QUITE THOSE BY
NINETY LAS.
LOS BEEN OVERLOADED SONG BEST
BUDDIES ON THE PROGRAM. BUT NOT
HIM.
AFTER THREE VIOLATIONS PROVIDERS
CAN BE SUSPENDED FROM THE
PROGRAM FOR NINETY DAYS AND THAT
THERE FOR VIOLATIONS PROVIDERS
ARE TERMINATED FROM THE ICE HAS
AS PROGRAM. UP FOR A YEAR.
IT BUT I'M NOT.
IT.
IT'S GONNA PUT AWAY LORD SOLO TO
SEE IT IT'LL SOLVE EASELS.
MAY NOT IS INGLIS.
PROBLEM IS THAT PROVIDERS ONLY
RECEIVE THESE VIOLATION NOTICES
IN ENGLISH.
ETHEL ADVOCATES WILL SAY THE
MISSILE SAID THE ARMY.
THAT'S THE BEAT THE DEATH
PENALTY LAW THIS.
THEN A THOUGHT HIT OF THAT THE
AMPLE.
WE GOT OUR BEST.
GOING TO HANDLE.
IT'S NINE PM LOOK AT THE
HACIENDA I WILL MONTH.
BUT GAY IN THE BOTTLE SOLO MAN
BILL I RESOURCE AND.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENED IN ME I
RECEIVED THREE TIME SHEETS AND
EACH TIME I DID NOT UNDERSTAND
THAT I WAS DOING WRONG. BECAUSE
THE STATE ONLY SENT ME NOTICES
IN ENGLISH.
NESTLE STEP INSIDE CABLE THE I
SAID THAT'S BIG DEAL THAT
PROGRAM OF THAT BITES.
SORRELL BOOKE QUE MOMENT THEN
THE LINE FOR MUST FEEL.
THING AT THE MOMENT THOUGH ESTO
DRIVE ON THE BOTTOM WE COULD
HAND THAT SEEM PART SEEMED PARA.
MAN DOT LUCIO BUSHEL BIN SOON
BUT LESS OPEN SHOWN THAT OVER
INTO THE UC GET ACV.
IT SCARES ME TO THINK THAT I
COULD BE TERMINATED FROM THE AYE
TO SAYS PROGRAM JUST BECAUSE I
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THE
INFORMATION.
RIGHT NOW I AM WORKING FOR MY
CLIENT UNPAID AS I FIGHT THE
NINETY DAY SUSPENSION THAT I
RECEIVED.
THAT'S GOING TO GET SERVICES
COULD BE DONE ALICE BRILEY
THOUGH IT IS.
THE THING IS THAT THIS WILL MEAN
THIS NSW UP EVEN IF THEY MEDI
VIEW ON.
NO SIEMPRE FOR THEM ONE GOING
PATENT TROUBLED DOOR.
IMMORTAL MANTLE'S ENTITLED DON'T
GET WEATHER INTIMIDATE MOST
OBVIOUS BUT IT IS THOUGHT.
RENT COMMUNICATION PROVIDES.
PROVIDERS SHOULD BE ABLE SUCKS
USING WRITTEN COMMUNICATIONS
SHIP.
TO PROVIDERS SHOULD BE ABLE TO
IN OUR.
SHOULD BE AVAILABLE IN OUR FIRST
LANGUAGE WE ARE NOT ALWAYS ABLE
TO FIND A TRANSLATOR MUCH LESS A
TRANSLATOR WHO CAN UNDERSTAND
THE NOTICES. FROM THE STATE.
I WOULDN'T PUT AWAY NOTED THAT
BIN THEN THE LOS NINOS.
BUT I PUBLIC STATE LINE FOR MY
CEILING.
THEY MIGHT ONLY KNOW THAT
BUNDLED AND THEN THEY HAVE. IT
THAT I MAY DO FOR MY FILM.
THE LIST THOUGHTFUL
SO DID THE HEAD OF THAT THE
AMPLE THE EYES.
SOME PROVIDERS RELY ON THEIR
CHILDREN TO TRANSLATE THE
INFORMATION CAN YOU IMAGINE A
CHILD TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
INCOME BAY INFORMATION FROM THE
STATE. ABOUT I JUST AS TIME SHE.
GO THEY BEND OVER ME THAT I'M
I'M I PROBABLY THAT PROGRAM OF
THE KINDS.
BUT I CUIDADO MI FIVE MEDIA.
IMMEDIATE THEY THAT BEEN THERE
THEY ME.
BUT I'M OF THEN AS A THING ORDER
SO LOUDLY INKATHA.
I RELY ON MY JOB THROUGH I JUST
SAYS PRO THE I JUST AS PROGRAM
TO TAKE CARE OF MY FAMILY AND MY
CLIENT RELIES ON ME. TO STAY
SAFE AND HEALTHY AT HOME.
IT MAY LOOK UP WHAT IN THE BUT I
GET THE THE LADY. BATTLES
PRIORITIES.
WELL MORE DON'T.
ONE BUT IN THAT NOT A LOT SCHOOL
MONEY GOT SOON ASSIST COULD EAT
THAT LITTLE RAMA ICED.
EASY GUNK WE GONDAL.
THEN LET'S SEE THEN THAT MUST
BORNE THAT OUT OF THE
CALIFORNIA.
OBVIOUS.
MEANING OVERSEE ENDORSED THE IS
SET ON WOMEN.
IT'S SAID PROJECT THOUGH IT
LAYING.
GARCIA.
THIS COULD BRING.
I ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SO THAT PROVIDERS LIKE ME CAN
UNDERSTAND WRITTEN
COMMUNICATIONS FROM THE I JUST
AS PROGRAM.
I AM CONTINUE CARING FOR
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE.
RESIDENTS.
PLEASE SUPPORT.
AB NINETEEN ZERO NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OUR MOTION.
IN A SECOND AYE ANYONE IS IN
SUPPORT.
AND MELISSA AND MO WHICH I ORDER
ENTRY ON BEHALF OF THE FRESNO
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE NICOLE RISA
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION TO SUPPORT.
GAP ROTH ON BEHALF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
KELLY BREAKS ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISOR OF SANTA
CLARA AND VENTURA COUNTIES HERE
IN SUPPORT.
JUSTIN GARRETT CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT.
IF ANYONE WITH THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
SUPPORT.
AND YOUR LANGLEY ON BEHALF OF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON BEVERLY YOU.
WITH YOU W. ASKED ME LOCAL
THIRTY NINE THIRTY AS A CO
SPONSOR THE BILL WE LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AS WELL CWD A
FOR THEIR WORK. WE STRONGLY
BELIEVE PROVIDERS HAVE ACCESS TO
TRANSLATIONS IF THEY NEED IT AND
MANY OF OUR PROVIDERS EXPERIENCE
THE SAME LANGUAGE PROBLEMS AS
YOU HEARD TODAY SO WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THINKING.
I AM OUR SOLO FROM BUTTE COUNTY
NOT SUPPORT THE BILL.
ME NUMBER IS MARKED THAT REYES.
AND REPRESENT ARE GONE THOUGH
THIS SAGA DISTRICT ON WINDOWS
HAYES YOU EMPLOY YOUR LOBBY USE
YOU KNOW THIS AND ON MY WAY
MUSKETS THIS ONE US WILL PICK
UP.
BUT A KIND OF THAT MISSILE TUBES
GUESSES
MY NAME IS MARTHA REEVES I AM IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN OH NINE.
AND MARTHA ALSO MENTIONED THAT
THIS IS A PLEAD FOR THE NON
ENGLISH SPEAKERS TO REALLY HAVE
THESE FORMS IN OUR LANGUAGE SO
WHERE IN SUPPORT OF NINETEEN ON
I. THINK YOU.
GARCIA BUT US WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
JOSH WILL GO WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY OF.
ANY MEMBERS BUT QUESTIONS.
MISTER EMILY.
YOU CAN ALWAYS HEAR GLASS SLS
AND YADA SWAN SONG MORE
IMPORTANT THEY CAN ALSO PRESS
ESCUCHADO AND LOSS THAT LAS
PERSONAS GET PROBABLE CAUSE OF
THE.
YOU GET ALL THIS YEAR GRASS IS
PART OF THE TEAM.
NICK.
THAT JURY.
I CANNOT SPEAK IN SPANISH BY
THANK YOU FOR COMING AND THE
TESTIFYING.
A ASSEMBLY MY OF NAZARIAN THANK
YOU FOR.
.
AUTHORING DECIDE IMPORTANT BR
IDEA TOTALLY OAK WE.
ONE SO FAR WHAT I'VE.
HERE.
OF ONE OF HEARD UP BUT NOW I
HAVE US MORAL QUESTION HERE.
THIS ONE WAS SO ORIGIN ON THE
ARE IN MY INTERPRETATION HE
ANALYSIS ON NOTICES OF WHAT
ACTION.
ST IN TWO LANGUAGES ARE SPOKEN
BY SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF BOOKS
IN HOME SUPPORTING US SERVICES
SO.
SO OUR I WAS A SPEAKING WITH MY
STAFF FOR WHAT THE SUBSTANTIAL
NUMBER.
MEANS UP BUT NOW I HEAR YOU
HAVE A SPECIFIC LANGUAGES SO A
SPANISH TO CHINESE ARE AND THEN
ARMENIAN.
BUT NOW WHAT ABOUT THE OTHER
LANGUAGES SO SUCH AS SOLVE
MYSELF FOR MY MOTHER'S HAVE
BEEN.
TAKEN CARE OF LOWER YOU OUR AYE
ITCHES SO THERE THERE'S A IT AT
AS A PERSON AND DOES SHE HELD SO
HAS SO CITIES SIMILAR.
BECAUSE SHE'S A FACING SIMILAR
NO QUESTION SO I THINK THAT WHAT
THE IE HEARD DONE.
THROUGH OUT MY STAFF
INTERPRETATION OF SUBSTANTIAL
WILL ASSIST YOU GRAPHICALLY THAT
THE SUBSTANTIAL LANGUAGE OF MAY
BE DIFFERENT FROM ONE AREA.
IDEOLOGICAL RUSSIAN SPEAKING A
IN HOME SERVICES ARE PROVIDERS
SO IN OTHER PLACES MAY NOT BE
ABOVE COME AND MAYBE MORE KOREAN
SPEAKING AND THERE.
ARE THE SAME TRANSLATION SERVICE
SO WOULD BE NECESSARY HOW.
ARE YOU WHEN I SUGGEST THAT
THOSE KIND OF PROBLEMS.
A ENABLE CERTAIN EXTENT
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER. A OF LOVE
PROVIDERS.
I I WILL LET CATHY ANSWERED IN
GREAT DETAIL BUT I HAD THE SAME.
QUESTION AND INTEREST AND.
WAS.
RIGHT.
WHEN I LOOKED AT THE NUMBERS IT
WAS SO VERY REVEALING.
OF.
AT THE LANGUAGE IS SPOKEN BY
THE PROVIDERS.
AND.
CREAN IS AMONGST THEM.
BUT.
I THINK THE NEXT TWO LANGUAGES
WHO WHICH RANK HIGHER THAN
CREATING. OUR COULD UNIT NOW
MEAN DISEASE YES YES SO THEY ARE
IN AN ORANGE COUNTY VIETNAMESE
SO WOULD BE A VERY HIGH NUMBER
PASSED OUT OR THOSE CITIES ARE
LIKE I DON'T KNOW IN THIS
SACRAMENTO WHAT THE SITUATION
WOULD BE. IT MAY BECOME MINORITY
SO HOW WE CAN RECONCILE THAT
CANNELLA IN NO.
SUBSTANTIAL MINORITY LANGUAGES
ISSUES.
AS A MEMBER IT'S AN EXCELLENT
QUESTION CATHY GONNA SEE WTA
THE.
LANGUAGE THE SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER
LANGUAGE IS PULLED FROM THE
EXISTING REQUIREMENTS ELSEWHERE
IN CODE FOR THE.
RECIPIENTS OF SERVICE SO WE
JUST REPEATED THE SAME LANGUAGE
AND THEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES THROUGH
REGULATIONS HAS DEFINED THAT TO
MEAN MORE THAN FIVE PERCENT. OF
THE.
OF THE RECIPIENTS.
SPEAK THAT LANGUAGE SO WE HAVE
ASSUMED THAT THEY WOULD APPLY
THE SAME FIVE PERCENT THRESHOLD
TO THE PROVIDERS. THAT IN THE
STATE WIDE LANGUAGE THAT EXISTS
TODAY FOR THEIR RECIPIENTS IS A
STATE WIDE PERCENTAGE SO YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THE DEPENDING
ON WHAT COUNTY YOU MIGHT BE EN.
ON FOR EXAMPLE SACRAMENTO COUNTY
I KNOW HAS A LARGE RUSSIAN
SPEAKING POPULATION AS AS YOU
MENTIONED.
OR IN THE BAY AREA YOU MIGHT
HAVE SOME OF THE ASIAN
LANGUAGES.
OR IN LOS ANGELES AS AS AS WE
TALK WITH YOU ABOUT I THINK.
WE COULD CERTAINLY CONTINUE TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION I THINK
YOU'D PROBABLY WANT TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES. TO SEE IF
THEY COULD SEE THEIR WAY TO
CHANGING THAT DEFINITION SINCE
WE'VE SORT OF RELIED ON THAT FOR
THE RECIPIENTS WE APPLIED AT THE
SAME WAY TO THE PROVIDERS AND I
THINK I MEAN MY ASSUMPTION WOULD
BE FROM A POLICY PERSPECTIVE.
YOU'D WANT TO APPLY THE SAME
DEFINITION FOR BOTH THE
RECIPIENT AND THE PROVIDERS FOR
THE TRANSLATIONS SO THERE'S AN
INTEREST SEVEN SEEKING THAT
APARTMENT PERHAPS DROPPING THAT
PERCENTAGE DOWN SOMEWHAT. SO
THAT WE COULD AB PICK UP
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGES WOULD BE
VERY HAPPY TO ENGAGE IN THAT
CONVERSATION JUST HELPING YOU
UNDERSTAND WHERE WE GOT THAT
FROM AND HOW THAT DRIVES TO.
ENGLISH SPANISH ARMENIAN AND
CHINESE BEING THE FOR WRITTEN
LANGUAGES THAT WOULD BE
ENCOMPASSED ACROSS THOSE.
THAT FIVE PERCENT THRESHOLD
THAT IS.
APPLIED TO THE RECIPIENTS NOW.
MAY I ED THEM MIGHT TO SEND
SOUTH GUT FEELING IS THAT THE
RATHER THAN USING THAT THOUGH
ARTIFICIAL IF I PLACENTA.
AS LONG AS.
THERE WE A SOMEBODY THOUGHT
WILLING TO SERVE FOR A AS A
SERVICE PROVIDER AND NOW WITH
THE. LIMITED.
ENGLISH LANGUAGE ABILITY AND I
THINK OUR.
YOU KNOW SOCIAL SERVICES
DEPARTMENT. CAN HIRE TRANSLATOR
IS NOT GONNA TAKE ARE. TOO MUCH
MONEY.
YEAH AND THE MUST SO TRANSLATED
IF THE EVENING FILE ONE OF A
VERY. RARE A LANGUAGE ONCE YOU
HAVE IT. AND THEY CAN BE SHARED
THE WITH THE OTHER. YOU KNOW
BECAUSE I THOUGHT THAT
DOCUMENTATION WOULD BE ABOUT THE
SAME A THRUST OF. THE STATE
STATE DOES SO YOU CAN YOU CAN
YOU CAN DOWN MOLD THOUGH AND
THAT CAN BE EASILY SHARE OF THE
AND THE VERY MINIMAL ACOSTA. SO
THAT WAY WE CAN AVOID THE CATCH
TWENTY TWO SITUATION. NOT IF OUR
FRENCH YOU SO LET'S SAY SOMEBODY
WANTS TO PROVIDE AND THAT
HAPPENS TO BE. LACKING IN WHICH
ABILITY AND THEN I'LL WANNA HAVE
WHAT BEING A GOOD OF FRENCH
TRANSLATION. AND AND THAT ONE
SURVEY HAVE IF THERE BE MORE
FRENCH SPEAKING PEOPLE OR SIGN
UP FOR THAT THE.
INSTEAD WHAT I MEAN.
SO ARE AYE I THINK OF THAT WOULD
WITH THE ELECTRONIC AGE WANTS TO
TRANSLATE IT. AND THAT DOCUMENT
IS NOT GONNA CHANGE EVERY DAY UP
PROBABLY LAST A. GOOD THE THREE
TO FIVE YEARS SETTLEMENT WAS
DOCUMENTATION MUST TO TRANSLATE
IT I THOUGHT THE MINIMUM COST SO
WE CAN COVER JUST ABOUT THE ANY.
ANY LANGUAGE.
I'M VERY GLAD TO HEAR THAT AND
I'D LOVE TO WORK CONTINUE
WORKING WITH YOU.
AND IN EXPANDING.
THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR THIS
PROGRAM SO THANK YOU FOR SAYING
THAT YEAH I THINK OF MY
RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
I HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
WHICH LIKE CLOSE.
I THINK YOU FOR AFFORDING US THE
TIME YOU DID MISTER OKUN EAT
MUCH OF THE SETTING UP OF THE
NEATEST THEY.
JUST BECAUSE HE SEES BUT ALWAYS
ON BLANCA.
THAT'S.
OKAY PUNKY CULTURAL PLEASE.
RUBIO AYE.
REVEAL AYE DOCTOR CHOI.
I DON'T TO CHOI AYE AYE NOW.
ARAMBULA HIND MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE RAYOS.
STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
THURMOND DIE.
IT'S GOTTEN SIX ZERO.
THE MOTION WAS TO PASS THROUGH.
ASSEMBLY PREPARATIONS AND I GOT
OUT OF TWENTY SIX ZERO.
MR TO
.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS FIRST I WANT TO.
THANK YOU AND ALSO THE COMMITTEE
STAFF WILL WAS NICE SEEING YOU
HERE. FULL WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL. A. B. NINETEEN NINETY
TWO IS A BILL TO HELP FAMILY
RECEIVING CAL WORKS.
COMPLY WITH THE AIM OF AYE THEY
SHOULDN'T REQUIREMENTS.
CURRENTLY FAMILY RECEIVING CAL
WORKS OF BENEFIT ARE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE PROOF FALL FOR HUMAN
LIFE THE SHINS FOR CHILDREN'S
AGE FIVE AND UNDER.
WOULD NOT PROVE THEIR BENEFITS
ARE REDUCED BY HUNDRED THIRTY
DOLLARS PER MONTH.
THAT IS SUCH A GOOD CHUNK OF
MONEY FOR THOSE FAMILIES
WATER SON MY THINK THAT THOSE
PARENTS HAVE MADE THE CHOICE TO
HELP YOUR KIDS GO WITHOUT. VETS
NATION
DID RESEARCH ACTUALLY SHOWS THAT
IT'S MORE LIKELY BILL FAMILY
THAT DIDN'T LACK OF THEIR*
TO HEALTH SERVICES.
FULL FAMILY LIVING IN ENDED A
DEEP PROPERTY.
SO INSTEAD OF PENALIZING THOSE
FAMILIES AB NINETEEN NINETY TWO
WILL HELP PROVIDE RESOURCES
INCLUDING TRANSPORTATION FOR
THOSE FAMILIES TO OBTAIN
NECESSARY BUTTON NATION FOR
THEIR CHILDREN.
THAT HERE WITH ME TODAY IS JUST
A CALL BOX LOW. FROM THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY.
AND GENEROUSLY NUMBER CANNELLA
LOAN. FROM THE CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND BOTH ORGANIZATION
ARE SPONSORING THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO ASK NOW IN
WITH CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA WORK CO SPONSORING AB
NINETEEN AT NINETY TWO.
CURRENTLY OF THE FAMILY
RECEIVING CAO WORKS IS UNABLE TO
PROVIDE PROOF OF IMMUNIZATION
WITHIN FORTY FIVE DAYS. THEIR
CAO WORKS GRANT IS REDUCED.
AB NINETEEN NINETY TWO SUPPORTS
CHILDREN IN FAMILIES BY
EXTENDING THE TIME A FAMILY HAS
TO VERIFY IMMUNIZATION FROM
FORTY FIVE DAYS TO SIX MONTHS.
FAMILIES WITH LOW INCOMES CAN
ENCOUNTER SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS
TO TIMELY IMMUNIZATION FOR THEIR
YOUNG CHILDREN.
RESEARCH SHOWS PARENTS MAY LACK
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT IMMUNIZATION OR
UNDERSTANDING THE COMPLICATED
COMPLICATED IMMUNIZATION
SCHEDULE FOR YOUNG CHILDREN OR
WHERE TO GO TO GET THEM.
THEY MAY HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
IMMUNIZATIONS SAFETY OR THEY MAY
BE UNAWARE OF THE THREAT F
VACCINE PREVENTABLE DISEASES.
AB NINETEEN NINETY TWO IN THE
SIX MONTH EXTENSION WILL GIVE
FAMILIES NEEDED TIME TO OBTAIN
IMMUNIZATIONS.
BEFORE SCHOOL FOR THEIR BEFORE
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN AND BEFORE
THE GRANTS ARE REDUCED AS A
PENALTY.
A. B. NINETY TO NINETEEN NINETY
TWO WOULD ALSO ENSURE THAT
COUNTY SUPPORT FAMILIES BY
PROVIDING TRANSPORTATION AND
INFORMATION ABOUT VACCINE SAFETY
VACCINE PREVENTABLE DISEASE AND
CLINICS PROVIDING NO COST
IMMUNIZATION.
RESEARCH SHOWS PENALTIES DO NOT
INCREASE IMMUNIZATION RATES THEY
SIMPLY DRIVE FAMILIES FURTHER
INTO POVERTY.
RESEARCH ALSO SHOWS THAT
SUPPORTING FAMILIES WITH
INFORMATION DOES DOES ACTUALLY
INCREASE IMMUNIZATION RATES.
AB NINETEEN NINETY TWO WILL
SUPPORT FAMILIES AND INCREASED
IMMUNIZATION AND CHILDREN
YOUNGER THAN SCHOOL AGE AND FOR
THESE REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
OKAY.
I COMMAND CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE DOES HAVE ARE FULL OF
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY ALSO CO SPONSORED THE
BILL IN ADDITIONTO THE THINGS
OTHER THE BILL HAS ALREADY BEEN
MENTIONED TO DO. I WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT IT ALSO REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT TO REGULARLY INFORM
AT THE PUBLIC IN THE LEGISLATURE
ABOUT THE STATUS OF THE
VACCINATION COMPLIANCE. THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE.
AS MY COLLEAGUE TO THE LEFT OF
ME CAN ATTEST FOR YEARS WE
REQUESTED THIS INFORMATION IT
TOOK A LONG TIME TO GET IT.
AND WHEN WE GOT IT IT WAS A
PROFOUNDLY DISTURBING TO LEARN
ABOUT THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN WHO
ARE DEEPLY IMPOVERISHED GOING
WITHOUT VACCINATION AND A
DEPARTMENT HAS. NO IDEA WHY WE
DON'T KNOW TO THIS DAY WHETHER
OR NOT IT'S BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T
THEY ABILITY TO VERIFY THEY'VE
LOST A VERIFICATION DID
HOMELESSNESS OR DOMESTIC THING
DOMESTIC ABUSE. WE DON'T KNOW TO
THIS DAY IF THEY COULD USE A
LITTLE HELP AND THAT WOULD HELP
THEM TO TO OF VERIFY. ALREADY IN
THE LAW THERE'S AN OPT OUT
PROVISION FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE A
MEDICAL OR PERSONAL BELIEF SO IT
ISN'T BECAUSE OF THAT.
IT'S BECAUSE THEY ACTUALLY
AREN'T THERE ART VACCINATED AND
AND NOT FOR ANY OTHER REASON.
SO THIS IS REALLY TROUBLING TO
ME THAT WE.
HAVE GOTTEN THIS FAR TWENTY
YEARS OF THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM
AND WHAT IT SUGGESTS IS THAT
THIS POLICY WAS NEVER INTENDED
TO MAKE SURE THAT KIDS.
WERE VACCINATED. THIS WAS THAT
THIS THIS PROVISION OF THE LAW
WAS PASSED UNDER PETE WILSON AND
IMPLEMENTED BY ELOISE ANDERSON
AND.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT IF THEY HAD
REALLY INTENDED FOR PEOPLE TO.
VERIFY THAT THE CHILDREN WILL
BECOME A VACCINATED THERE WOULD
HAVE BEEN THIS KIND OF INTEREST
INTERVENTION FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
FAMILIES WHEN THEY WEREN'T ABLE
TO VERIFY THAT THE NATION. THAT
THEY WERE SUPPORTED TO FIND
THEIR WAY TO A VACCINATION
CLINIC.
SO I'M I'M THRILLED BEYOND
WORDS THAT A BITASSEMBLYMEMBER
HAS AGREED TOOK UP.
AND OFFER THIS PROVISION REALLY
URGE ALL OF YOU TO SUPPORT IT OF
I THINK THAT WILL REDUCE
CHILDHOOD POVERTY BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY.
LEAD TO HEALTH CARE KITS.
COULD HAPPEN KEVIN AS THE CHORUS
CALIFORNIA OFFER RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS CLOSE SPONSORING
THE BILL. IN URGING THE IBOOK
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DO I HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SELENA PIRACY ALIEN SUPPORT.
MONICA SAMI ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAMS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
AT A PREMIUM OR FROM THE CHILD
CARE LAW CENTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
KATE JUST FOR CLARIFICATION
MISTER TO WE HAVE.
I HAVE A DO PASSED AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENT.
UNTIL.
THANK YOU.
NOPE NO CULTURES I I JUST WANT
TO AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND PRAY EMPHASIZED AT THIS BILL
ACTUALLY YOU KNOW NOT WHAT WHAT
I WAS ASKING IS THAT I HAVE A
RECOMMENDATION TO.
PASS.
AS AMENDED AND I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE YOU'RE ALL GOOD
GOVERNMENT AMENDMENT DEFINITELY
WE'RE HAPPY TO LEAD INTO TAKE
TILL SOME AMETEK WHO ARE MUCH.
THANK YOU.
DEMON.
KATE THE THE AMENDMENTS ARE ARE.
TO CLARIFY THE POPULATION OF
CHILDREN TO WHOM THE
IMMUNIZATION REQUIREMENT APPLIES
AND CLARIFY. AND RE ORGANIZE
TIMELINES AND PROCESSES THAT'S
IN.
THE BILL.
GET ANY OTHER COMMENT ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE YOU ARE
COMMITTEE.
CONDUCT CHOI.
I HAVE A QUESTION NOT TO
SOMEONE.
CHU.
I THINK THIS IS SO WELL
INTENDED. A BILL A.
EXTENDING.
THE A ARE IMMUNIZATION TERRY THE
FINAL FORTY FIVE DAYS TO SIX
MONTHS.
AGAIN I HAD A CONVERSATION WITH
MY CONSULTANTS ARE AND A STAFF
MEMBER SO. WHERE THIS HAS SIX
MONTH SO?
I HAVE COME FROM.
THAT IS SO TO ME I'M GUESSING
IS SOMEWHAT FLEXIBLE REASONABLE
TIME FOR FAMILIES TO.
TO FIND TIME.
AND THAT'S GET AROUND TO IT THAT
PICKED THE CHILDREN TO.
FANS AT THE ME THAT FOR
IMMUNIZATION.
HOWEVER OUT DURING THAT TIME
BECAUSE THE SIX MONTHS THAT CAN
BE A LONG TIME FOR YOU OUR
LITTLE CHILDREN UNDER AGE ALL
FIVE.
SINCE OUR ARMED I A RECENTLY
HAD THOUGH ALCUIN CHILD.
I THOUGHT ABOUT TO HAPPEN.
IF FOR MY DAUGHTER. A DELAYING.
NECESSARY YEAR IMMUNIZE DEJAN.
WELL IT IS TO DO AFTER TWO
MONTHS OF THE BOOK.
BUT DOT AND AUGUST SIXTH TWO
MONTHS SO SHE HAS TO WAIT THE
BECAUSE ISSUES UP.
UNABLE TO GET TO FOR WHATEVER
REASON.
ISN'T THAT THAT EXPORTS SINGLE
CHILD INTO DANGER.
HOW COULD CURRENT MEDICALLY?
IT MAY BE DOING THAT THAT
CRITICAL TIME.
I THINK WE HAVE OUR DOCTOR
PEDIATRICIAN CAN ANSWER THAT
QUESTION HOPE WHAT THE DATA SO.
NEGLIGIBLE PURE YET.
WALK CRITICAL TIME FOR CHILDREN
TO GET E. R. IMMUNIZATION IN
TIME.
MAYBE EITHER YOU CAN S. SO WHY
YOU CAN ASK A ASSEMBLYMAN. ADAM
WHAT CAN THEN WELL LET ME GIVE
DE AFFAIRS SHOP AND THEN DOCTOR
RAMBLER THAT DEFINITELY CAN
CHINA. FOR.
YEAH PRESIDENT ALL AND I. BUT
THE AND IT AGAIN IT AND SIX
MONTHS.
YOU MAY THINGS A LITTLE BIT LONG
BUT WE WANTED TO GIVE IT
PROVIDERS AND HE LOOKED AT THE
COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENT. AS
WELL. AS TO FAMILY AND AMPLE
TIME TO TO WORK TOGETHER. THE
SHOTS THAT THEY NEED IS NOT
SAYING THAT I THOUGHT ONE WAY
FOR THE CONVENIENCE OF THE
ADULTS BUT NOT OF ME ABOUT A
HOUSE THE EXPOSURE OF THE
CHANGED EXACTLY AND I UNDERSTAND
YOUR CONCERN. BUT I WILL SAY IS.
WITH ALL DUE TO CERTAIN IN
NINETEEN NINETY TWO DOES
CHILDREN'S WE GO. EVEN LONGER
WITHOUT.
AND IMAGINATION.
SO DISTANT DISPEL HAVE NO IMPACT
TO DATE DILUTED TO THE HEALTH.
OWN OR DID RISK
OF TO CHILDREN IT WILL ONLY
IMPROVE LAURIE IT REDUCED THE
RISK OF THE CHILDREN.
BECAUSE NOW WE'RE PROVIDING A
HOME AND THEN DONE THE TO
TRANSPORTATION AND ALL THOSE
NECESSARY STEP.
TO TO HELP THEM TO GET THE SHOTS
THINGY.
I WOULD LIKE TO DO IT OR ANY
PROVIDING UNNECESSARY RESOURCE
SUNRISE I TRUST PROTEST RABA
ENDING AS A ONE GAME LEAD THEM
BUT TODAY EXTENSION IS SO WHAT
ARE I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE WAY
THAT THAT'S THE CRITICAL TIME
IS.
REALLY GOOD FOR CHILDREN ARE
NOT.
RIGHT THE A AGAIN I JUST WANT TO
REPEAT THAT. WOULD ALL THIS BILL
DOES CHILDREN COULDN'T COOK MAKO
EVEN LONGER. WITH. AND MEDICINE
NATION.
SO DOES BILL WOULD.
WE WILL GO AND EDUCATE THEM
ANGER ANYWAYS DR.
CHURCH SO JUST FOR CLARIFICATION
I WORKED IN THE EMERGENCY ROOM
AND NOT AS A PEDIATRIC.
IN AND SECOND I WOULD CONCUR
THAT THE SOONER WE CAN GET THE
VACCINATIONS THE BETTER BUT
THOSE ARE INDIVIDUAL CHOICES
BETWEEN PATIENTS AND PROVIDERS.
IT SEEMS THAT THIS BILL IS
ATTEMPTING TO GET PATIENTS TO
PROVIDERS IN A MORE TIMELY
FASHION. AND TO PROVIDE
RESOURCES WITH THAT AND I SEE A
REAL BENEFIT TO THAT.
BUT ANY OTHER ONE THING THAT I
COULD JUST ADD.
YOU KNOW THAT THE.
THE IMMUNIZATION SCHEDULE LET
THE DOCTORS TELL US ALL TO
IMMUNIZE A CHILDREN WITH THEN
ISN'T CHANGING AT ALL RIGHT THAT
WILL STILL BE THE SAME. AND WHAT
WAS MOLD CHANGES IF THE FAMILY
DOESN'T PROVIDE VERIFICATION.
THEY'RE NOT CUT OFF BENEFITS
THAT'S THE ONLY THING THAT WILL
CHANGE THEY'RE NOT SANCTION THE
BENEFITS AND WE ALREADY KNOW
THAT THAT SANCTION OF BENEFITS.
ISN'T RETURNING THE CHILDREN
BACK TO GET VACCINATION INSTEAD
IT'S CUTTING THE PARENT AND THE
SUPPORT SERVICES TO GET THE
VACCINATION.
OFF FROM THAT FAMILY AND THAT'S
WHY IT'S ELONGATING THE PERIOD
OF TIME AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE
THOUSANDS OF KIDS UNVACCINATED
AND WE HAVE NO CONNECTION TO
THEIR PARENTS TO HELP GET THEM
BACK IN. TO VACCINATE.
SO THAT'S THAT'S WHY THE BILL
I'M WORKS TO ACTUALLY SHORTENED
FOR THIS VERY REASON HAS WORKED
WE'RE VERY CONCERNED JUST LIKE
YOU.
AND CONGRATULATIONS FOR YOUR
PICK BONTA.
WE'RE VERY CONCERNED THAT THESE
CHILDREN ARE GOING WITHOUT
VACCINATIONS AND WHAT'S WHAT
WE'VE LEARNED IS THAT THE
CURRENT INTERVENTION TO CUT THEM
OFF FROM BENEFITS. IS ACTUALLY
HAVING THE OPPOSITE EFFECT OF
BRINGING THEM BACK IN SO INSTEAD
OF DOING THAT.
OFFERING THEM HELP UP TO GET THE
VACCINATED AND AND WITH URGENCY.
WHAT THE FACT THAT WE HAVE NO
IDEA WHAT THE FORTY FIVE THIS
CAME FROM?
WAS OUT OF THE BLUE SKY.
SO THAT'S ONE THING THE SECOND
THING IS THAT THE SIX MONTH OF
THE MEAT THAT YOU HAVE TO TAKE A
POLL FIX MONTH. YOU COULD TAKE
FIFTY DAYS SIXTEENTH PENDING FOR
WHATEVER TEN DAYS. IMAGE JUST
GIVE PEOPLE MAXWELL FLEXIBILITY
GIVEN THE FACT THAT IT TAKES
MONTHS TO GET AN APPOINTMENT
THESE DAYS WITH THE DOCTOR.
WITHOUT ACTED IN THE SEVENTIES
OF THE SIXTIES YOU WENT THERE
THEY SAW YOU DON'T HAPPEN NO
MORE. THIS OF THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY.
SO THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO GIVE
PEOPLE MORE FLEXIBILITY.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MCCALLUM.
I HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
.
AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
THE THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIGHTS
BOAT.
THANK AND I DO HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND TO DOUG DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CAN YOU
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
RUBIO AYE REVEAL AYE DOCTOR
CHOI.
DIET DOCTOR CHOI I HAVE ARAMBULA
ON THEM BUT I MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE RAYOS.
STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
BERMAN I BELIEVE SINCERE.
I GAVE HIM BILLS OUT HERE SIX
THERE THANK YOU.
AND MISTER MINTON
.
YEAH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
.
I'LL START WITH SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR IS THAT MANAGER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I WANNA
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE
ON AMENDMENTS AYE AND I WILL BE
ACCEPTING ALL THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. THE CURRENT
CALIFORNIA FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
RESULTS IN TOO MANY CHILDREN
BEING MOVED FROM HOME TO HOME
TOO FREQUENTLY.
WHEN CHILDREN UNDERGO MULTIPLE
PLACEMENTS THEY ARE LIKELY TO
EXPERIENCE SEVERE TRAUMA.
THIS TRIAL MANIFESTS ITSELF
MANIFESTS ITSELF BEHAVE MORALLY
EMOTIONALLY SOCIALLY AND
ACADEMICALLY MAKING IT LESS
LIKELY FOR THESE FOSTER YOUTH
DEFINED PERMANENCE AND ADOPTION
A REUNIFICATION.
STUDIES SHOW A MAJOR REASON FOR
FAMILIES TO REQUEST REMOVAL
FOSTER CHILDREN FROM THEIR HOMES
IS DUE TO INSUFFICIENT
COMMUNICATION AND SUPPORT FROM
THE CHILD'S CASE WORKER.
ADDITIONALLY THE PRE PLACEMENT
TRAINING THAT BOSTROM KINSHIP
FAMILIES RECEIVE IS NOT
SUFFICIENT. TO ADDRESS THE
COMPLEX NEEDS OF CHILDREN AND
POST PLACEMENT CARE.
TO ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FOR WILL
ESTABLISH A TWO YEAR PILOT
PROPRIOCEPTIVE BITING ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT TO FOSTER AND KINSHIP
CAREGIVERS. VIA POST PLACEMENT
COACHING THIS COACHING PILOT
WILL HELP FACILITATE THE CARE
GIVERS TRANSFER OF LEARNING FROM
THE CLASSROOM TO THEIR
EXPERIENCES WITH CHILDREN PLACE
IN THE HOME. WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE PREPAREDNESS OF AND
SUPPORT FOR RESOURCE FAMILIES BY
PROVIDING THIS COACHING THE
PILOT PROGRAM WILL IMPROVE
PLACEMENT STABILITY THEREBY
REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF TRAUMA
SUFFERED BY FOSTER YOUTH.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FOUR IS
MICHELLE EVANS A MCGEORGE SCHOOL
OF LAW STUDENT AND MEMBER OF THE
LEGISLATIVE AND PUBLIC POLICY
CLINIC. AND JENNIFER REX ROAD
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CAREGIVERS.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN RUBIO
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT MY NAME
IS MICHELLE EVANS AND I AM A
STUDENT AT THE MCGEORGE SCHOOL
OF LAW PARTICIPATING IN THE
LEGISLATIVE AND PUBLIC POLICY
CLINIC. I AM ALSO A LICENSED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND HAVE
BEEN A SOCIAL WORKER FOR NEARLY
NEARLY TWENTY YEARS.
I SUPPORT AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR AND ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
BECAUSE THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE
FOR MUCH NEEDED SUPPORT.
TO OUR MOST VALUABLE RESOURCE
AND THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM OUR
KINSHIP AND FOSTER FAMILIES.
WHEN CHILDREN ARE REMOVED FROM
THEIR HOME AND FAMILY AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
MENTIONED THEY EXPERIENCE TRAUMA
AND THE EXPERIENCE FURTHER
TRAUMA WITH THEIR MOVE FROM HOME
TO HOME TO GROUP HOME. TO
ANOTHER HOME TO RESIDENTIAL
PLACEMENT AND THIS MAKES IT
REALLY DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
BONDS AND ATTACKED WITH FUTURE
FAMILIES. AND MEETING WITH
CHILDREN MYSELF I'VE HAD THEM
TELL ME THINGS SUCH AS.
FEELING ALONE AND CARED FOR
THEY FEEL LIKE THROWAWAYS I'VE
EVEN HAD THEM TELL ME THEY JUST
FEEL LIKE TRASH AND THEY NEVER
WANT TO. BINDER ATTACHED WITH
ANOTHER FAMILY AGAIN THEY JUST
LOSE THEIR HOPE.
WE CAN DO BETTER THAT MESS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE CAN
PROVIDE FAMILIES WITH A
DESIGNATED PERSON. TO ASSIST THE
FAMILIES AND HELPING CHILDREN
MAKE THE TRANSITION INTO THEIR
HOME.
HELP THEM BONDED ATTACHED WITH
THE CHILD HELP THEM WORK WITH
THE BIOLOGICAL FAMILY TOWARDS
REUNIFICATION AND EFFECTIVELY
PARTICIPATE AND CHILD AND FAMILY
TEAM MEETINGS.
THIS IS ALSO A CRITICAL TIME AND
DURING THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
CCR.
WHERE CHILDREN ARE BEING BROUGHT
OUT OF GROUP HOMES WHICH IS A
REALLY GOOD THING INTO FAMILY
SETTINGS THE DIFFICULTY IS THAT
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH FAMILIES?
WHO ARE PREPARED AND QUALIFIED
TO CARE FOR THOSE CHILDREN
COMING OUT OF GROUP HOMES AND
I'VE BEEN TOLD THAT THESE
CHILDREN BEING FORCED INTO
HOMES?
THAT AREN'T ADEQUATELY PREPARED
TO CARE FOR THEM AND MEET THEIR
NEEDS OR IF THEY'RE STAYING
LONGER THAN THEY NEED TO IN THE
GROUP HOME LANGUISHING. AND SO
THIS IS A AT THE VERY TIMELY AND
TO PROVIDE A DESIGNATED PERSON A
COACH TO SUPPORT THE PARENTING.
AND OF THESE INDIVIDUAL
FAMILIES.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FOUR FILS A
CRITICAL NEED FURTHERING THE
AIMS AND EFFORTS AT THE CC OUR
FOR EVERY CHILD TO LIVE AN
UNSTABLE COMMITTED AND NURTURING
FAMILY.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE.
I'LL GIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRWOMAN
AND MEMBERS.
I'M JENNIFER REX RAILROAD AND
I'M A FOSTER PARENT AND YELLOW
COUNTY.
AND I BELIEVE THAT RESOURCE
FAMILIES ARE ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT.
ASSETS OF THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM IF NOT THE MOST IMPORTANT
OUT SAID. AND ANY INVESTMENT
THAT THE STATE MAKES AN RESOURCE
FAMILY IS GREATLY IMPROVES THE
QUALITY OF CARE FOR CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE.
AND SUSTAINS THAT STATE ASSET.
COACHING BOOK EVERY SOURCE
FAMILY IT'S A PRACTICAL SUPPORT
THEY NEED TO IMPROVE THE TOOLS
AND THEIR PARENTING TOOLBOX
WHILE PUTTING THEIR STRENGTHENED
LEARNING. INTO PRACTICE WITH A
SPECIFIC CHILD OR CHILDREN IN
THEIR CARE.
IT WILL HELP PARENTS LEARN HOW
TO BOND WITH THE CHILDREN. I'M
IN THEIR CARE WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED TRAUMA AS WELL AS
SUPPORT THEM WITH PRACTICAL
APPLICATION. OF PARENTING SKILLS
THEY HAVE LEARNED IN AN
INDIVIDUALIZED WAY TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE CHILD OR CHILDREN
IN THEIR CARE.
I.
BRANDY RESOURCE FAMILIES TAKING
ON. THAT FIRST TIME PLACEMENT
AYE RELATIVES WHO'VE HAD NO
WARNING. OF A CHILD COMING INTO
THEIR CARE AND RESOURCE FAMILIES
WHO ARE.
TAKING CHILDREN FROM A HIGHER
LEVEL OF CARE ARE RESOURCE
FAMILIES WHO WE IN THE FIRST
NINETY DAYS.
COACHES AND CAN HELP THESE
FAMILY AND EFFECTIVELY
PARTICIPATE AND CHILD AND FAMILY
TEAM MEETINGS SO THAT THE NEEDS
OF.
OF THE CHILDREN AND THE
STABILITY OF THE PLACEMENT IS
ADDRESSED IN A TIMELY WAY
INAPPROPRIATELY.
COACHES CAN ALSO HELP RESOURCE
FAMILIES WORK WITH BIOLOGICAL
FAMILY IT'S AT SUPPORT RE
UNIFICATION. AND POTENTIALLY
ESTABLISHED LONG TERM SUPPORT
FOR FAMILIES TO REUNIFY.
RESOURCE FAMILIES NEED TO BE
SUPPORTED IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
THE HIGH QUALITY OF PARENTING
THAT WE AND EXPECT FOR CHILDREN
AND FOSTER CARE.
HELPING FAMILIES AND WITH THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED WHILE ALSO.
AND PREVENT
SEVEN DAY NOTICES WHICH IS WHEN
A FAMILY AND IT'S.
SO OVERWHELMED.
ON THAT THEY GIVE NOTICE TO THAT
APARTMENT THAT THINK THE CHILD
NEEDS TO MOVE. ON AND THAT'S
OBVIOUSLY CAUSES MORE.
TRAUMA FOR THE CHILD SO BY
ADDRESSING CHALLENGING
SITUATIONS BEFORE THEY CAN'T
BECOME A CRISIS. AND IT NOT ONLY
HELPS TO. AND.
TO PREVENT THREE TRUMPETED
NATION OF CHILDREN BUT ALSO TO
RETAIN ON FOSTER FAMILIES HILL
HAVE MADE THE COMMITMENT TO CARE
FOR CHILDREN THINK YOU SO MUCH.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND MELISSA MALL ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY
OF CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I KNEW WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
KATE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
AND WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND PLEASE.
I AND THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WHICH
LIKE CLOTHES THINK YOU AYE MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I'VE.
THANK YOU CAN CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
RUBIO AYE REVEAL AYE DOCTOR
CHOI.
DOCTOR CHOI AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA HI MAIENSCHEIN HI
MAIENSCHEIN I DAIS.
STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
THERE MIGHT HAVE A BILL SECURE.
THANK YOU THE BILL IS OUT ARE TO
APPROPRIATIONS SIX ZERO AND MR
MAIENSCHEIN YOU HAVE ANOTHER
BILL.
PAT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN
FACING HOMELESSNESS IN SAN IN
SAN DIEGO. SAN DIEGO TWO.
IN AND IN AMERICA IS AT AN ALL
TIME HIGH CURRENT LAW PROVIDES
TEMPORARY HOUSING ASSISTANCE TO
HOMELESS FAMILIES RECEIVING AID
THROUGH THE CALLASPO RAMP UP TO
SIXTEEN CONSECUTIVE NIGHTS IN A
HOTEL MOTEL. OR COMMERCIAL
ESTABLISHMENT BECAUSE THE
TEMPORARY HOUSING ASSISTANCE
CAPS AT SIXTEEN CONSECUTIVE DAYS
A BREAKING ASSISTANCE
INADVERTENTLY PUNISHES FAMILIES
TO VACATE THEIR TEMPORARY
LODGINGS FOR JUST ONE DAY. THE
RULE ITSELF ESTABLISHES A
DISINCENTIVE TO FIND ALTERNATIVE
ARRANGEMENTS.
SEEK PROSPECTIVE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR EMPLOYMENT OR TO LAND TO
PRESSING HEALTH OR FAMILY
OBLIGATIONS DURING THIS TIME
PERIOD FURTHERMORE DUE TO
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS OFTEN
CANNOT FIND A PERMANENT PLACE TO
LIVE. DUE TO A LACK OF OPTIONS
CURRENT LAW ONLY ALLOWS
PERMANENT HOUSING ASSISTANCE TO
BE USED IN A COMMERCIAL SETTING
SHELTER WITH THE PERSON WHO'S IN
THE BUSINESS OF RENTING
PROPERTY.
AB NINETEEN TWENTY ONE WILL
REMOVE THE REQUIREMENT THAT THE
SIXTEEN DAYS BE CONSECUTIVE.
AND WILL ELIMINATE THE
DISINCENTIVE TO REFUSE OR
INTERRUPT TEMPORARY HOUSING
ASSISTANCE ADDITIONALLY AB
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE WILL ALLOW
PERMANENT HOUSING ASSISTANT TO
BE USED TOWARDS SHARE HOUSING
SET SETTINGS.
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THIS BILL
TODAY I HAVE WITH ME KATHY
CENTER LANE WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
KEVIN AS LOT AS LONNIE AND WITH
THE COALITION OF CALIFORNIA
WELFARE RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS AND
JESSICA. BARTHOLOMEW WITHOUT A
BARCELO WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
KATHY CENTER LINK WITH THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION I'LL BE QUICK HAS
THE BILLS MOVED AND SECONDED AND
THAT'S YOUR LAST BILL. BUT ALL
THIS.
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
WITH US.
OVER SEVERAL BILLS IN SEVERAL
YEARS THE THREE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE CO SPONSORING TO REALLY
MAKE IMPROVEMENTS TO THIS
PROGRAM TO REFLECT THE REALITY
OF WHAT ARE. HOMELESS FAMILIES
AND HOW WORK SPACE WE KNOW THAT
THE NUMBER OF HOMELESS FAMILIES
INCREASE SHARPLY DURING THE
RECESSION BUT STILL RECOVERING
FROM THAT. AT A PARTICULAR ON
THE COUNTY'S BROUGHT US THIS
YEAR THE ISSUE OF THE SHARED
HOUSING BECAUSE THEY'VE HAD TO
TURN AWAY ANECDOTALLY WE DON'T
HAVE GREAT STATEWIDE DATA. BUT
ANECDOTALLY PEOPLE COME AND THEY
SAY I'M ABLE TO SUBLEASE.
A PORTION OF THIS HOMER THIS
APARTMENT ON THIS IS NOT
COMMITTEES MAY BE IN THE
BUSINESS OF OF LEASING OR THEY
HAVE TO SHARE THE HOUSING IT
SEEMS FINE IT SEEMS LEGIT BUT WE
ARE UNABLE TO PROVIDE THAT
ASSISTANCE TO THEM. PEOPLE CAN I
PLEASE HAVE THE LIVE IF THEY
FIND A SHARE HOUSING
ARRANGEMENTS ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO PROBABLY TAKE THAT AND FOREGO
THE ASSISTANCE THAT COULD HELP
THEM. YOU KNOW JUST KEEP THEIR
FUNDS AND NOT HAVE TO SPEND
THOSE.
EVERYBODY'S FROM THIS PROGRAM
IS ON SUCH ISSUES DURING WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT FIX TO
THE LAW AND URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
KATE AND JUSTIN BARTHA WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY.
AGAIN A CO SPONSOR THE BELL AND
I'LL BE BRIEF AS WELL SINCE THE
TH IT WAS SUMMARIZED VERY WELL
I'M BUT JUST TO LET YOU KNOW
THAT WE HAVE HAD CLIENTS OF CAL
WORKS. COME UP THROUGH OUR LEGAL
SERVICES TO WHOM WE PROVIDE
SUPPORT THROUGH.
IT'S ABOUT THAT THE STATE AND
WHO HAVE HAD A PROBLEM THERE
SIXTEEN DAYS WORTH OF
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING BENEFITS
TRUNCATED BECAUSE AS THEIR
SISTER ATHLETES AT LET THEM STAY
WITH THEM FOR A COUPLE NIGHTS IT
AS A REPRIEVE. OR BECAUSE THEY
HAD TO LEAVE AYE WHERE THEY WERE
SAYING TO GO UP FOR A JOB
INTERVIEW AT OF THE AREA AND SO.
IT HAS LITERALLY A LEFT PEOPLE
EITHER WITHOUT HOUSING OR
WITHOUT BEING ABLE TO.
TO TAKE THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN PRESENTED THEM I'M AND
FOR THESE REASONS REALLY ARCHER
AYE VOTE AND I THINK YOU AGAIN
FOR AUTHORING THE BILL.
NOT KEVIN AS THEIR CHORUS A
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION.
INSTRUCT SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SELENA PIRACY ISLANDS Q..
JUSTIN GET CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
GERMAN OF OR SOME HAVE THE URBAN
KINDS OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
YES COUNT CHILDREN'S DEFENSE
FUND CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
KELLY BREAKS ON BEHALF OF THE
SENATE CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND THE VENTURA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS BOTH
IN SUPPORT.
MONICA SEMI ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAM ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU AYE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
QUE HEARING YOU MICHAEL AND CUTS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS RESPECTFULLY REQUESTS
AND IVA.
I THINK YOU AYE I HAVE A MOTION
TO PASS THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY
PREPARATIONS CAN YOU CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE.
RUBIO ARE REAL BILL I KNOCKED
CHOI. BY DOCTOR CHOI I HAVE I'M
GONNA.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAIENSCHEIN AYE
THERE'S.
STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND. THURMOND
AYE.
SKIP FIVE ZERO
GIVE THE BILL IS OUT FIVE ZERO.
OKAY I WILL GO AHEAD AND OPEN
ITEM NUMBER TWO FOUR OUT ON
VOTES.
DO PASSED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DOCTOR CHOI.
DOCTOR JENNIFER.
DUTCH CHOI I KNOW. THAT I'M
GONNA.
THURMOND. THURMOND TANK.
IS THAT THE ONLY I DON'T.
IT WOULDN'T SEVERAL.
THAT.
BUT FURTHER THAT MIST MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
NO I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE MISTER
MINISTER.
OKAY.
PERFECT CHEMICAL HIDDEN LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR TEN MINUTES ON
FOR. MEMBERS THAT WANT TO
CONTINUE COMBAT.
BATES
.
OKAY.
WITH.
IT WILL GO AHEAD AND OPEN THE
ROLE FOR ADAMS.
ON THE NIGHT.
ITEM NUMBER ONE
.
AT NUMBER DAIS.
DOCTOR CHOI.
NO DUTCH TRADITION OF SERVING.
WE'RE DONE WITH THAT
.
GOOD
I. THANK YOU I'M WE WON'T HAVE
ANY OTHER MEMBERS COMING SO
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND ADJOURNED ACT
ON TO FORTY.
TWO THIRTY NINE